so i was with the parents the week
before in washington dc and this was not
planned but i decided to invite the guy
i was saying to dc and because the scene
called me out and she was like are you
eating alone i said no and we made a
trip out of it and during that trip come
on what
is going on i
like to party jesus honey
this is unwaxed get in loser we're going
shopping with sophia and sistine
stallone we just become best friends
[Music]
i do look like a
cool dad
nah not like a cool dad you look like
someone's agent like trying really hard
to look like a professional agent you
wanna hear something weird whenever i
see someone wearing glasses indoors
instantly i'm judging them
like do you think you're too cool for
school what are you hiding
why would you know what i mean but then
whenever i work like right now i feel
like such an [ __ ] no glasses inside
mean one thing
you're hungover you're high that's it
you're high or you're a hungover there's
no in between there's no way you're just
wearing it because it's fashion i mean
unless it is fashion unless it's
something cool that someone put together
i mean haley bieber wore it on the red
carpet to the met ball she wear glasses
she did
and i was like maybe you have a stye
that was the first thing i thought of
anyway welcome back to another episode
of the unwaxed podcast with your
favorite
sisters sorry
go ahead
i just love saying it it's been a bit so
i wanted to get into it obviously we're
a little rusty right now i feel like we
haven't been in the studio in quite some
time and
today is a super special episode because
it's a sister episode episode what was
the last time we've done that it's been
a bit since we just had a one-on-one
conversation every time we do these
no guest episodes it really takes me
back to the very birth of the unwax
podcast i know and we were struggling we
were writing topics that we needed to
talk about everything was so rehearsed
but it was fun it was yeah
what yeah it sucked because we were
inside it was during quarantine we hated
each other we did hate each other it was
like not only was it a pandemic and not
only were we working together eating
each other sleeping together we were
just unhappy being inside so we had so
true you know but i like this so much
better i feel like
this just makes it seem easier i don't
know or it's just been a year i feel
like i just feel less pressure because
sometimes when you have a guest on first
of all i i dress differently i'll
actually do my hair right now my hair is
so
gross
and now just being with you i feel chill
i can just
look like this
yeah the hat with the shirt and the
do you not like my hat too no it's fine
i actually bought this hat from my
boyfriend this weekend and i have a bad
habit of buying gifts for other people
and then liking it so much that i never
give it to them wait i did that to my
friend for her birthday uh so i had to
give her a birthday present so i gave
her a bunch of makeup and i took one of
the things it's for shout out colleen
i'm sorry i took one product what did
you take the self tanner
i was like the one thing you'd probably
like the most
of course because you're like a little
self-tanner female this is the thing i
remember i bought it i was thinking i
was like actually i kind of needed a
self-tanner to mix with my moisturizer
like daily and then i was like no no no
you know what i have like eight bottles
i don't need another one and so
literally right before leaving the door
pull it out of the bag toss into my bed
and run out so i don't think a second
thought about it you should i feel so
guilty all the way to the thing i was
like i should have just given it to her
i have a
problem be on
my strange addiction or something to
solve time oh wait first of all i don't
put that much self tanner on you
actually i do have eight bottles no but
of the ones for your body and like half
of them are out some am i just safe
are you in are you i have eight
[Laughter]
wait just can't wait i have four bottles
but then i have two for the face
okay sophia
you're really digging yourself back into
that hole is there anything recently
that you've been addicted to because i
remember a few episodes ago i had a
melatonin addiction
and the serving size is about 10
milligrams of melatonin and i took about
i'm not exaggerating 65 to 80 a day
that's not even that's not possible
i just no but i ate because i like them
in gummy form but i ate about 12 gummies
instead of two did you just fall asleep
for eight years i mean like there's no
way you could actually oh my god i'm so
sorry i didn't mean melatonin i meant
hair growth vitamins yeah
you were like were you just out i was
like you ate a hundred milligrams of
melatonin that's like dead that's like a
drug addict
that's
also that's kind of still bad
no that money so i didn't realize that
taking that much bio to not only does it
break you out i started growing hair
everywhere
all over my face
manscaped healthy
shut up
i mean i really had a problem but anyway
i've kicked my addiction because
um
it just wasn't good health-wise so is
there anything recently i know you're
addicted to almond butter but is there
something that you've just been kind of
obsessed with lately
um
yeah well i make smoothies every morning
and i actually can't i literally it
sounds so stupid but no i i'll make it
breakfast i'll make eggs toast
everything yes and then i'll start
eating it and hate it
and then make a smoothie and then i'll
i'll like let me throw out the food that
i just made i'm like why did i do that
i'm wasting money
and i'm being just too picky and of
course still almond butter at night i
have to have ice cream every single
night now i'm putting almond butter on
it on ice cream yes it's so good i knew
it was bad when you put almond butter on
yogurt i was like wait that's not bad
i've just never seen that before you've
never seen a yogurt parfait with like a
scoop of peanut butter is that not
normal oh
crickets crickets i feel like that's it
i don't have like that bad of anything
like you have always had a gummy
thing you've always loved gummies but
i've been taking um multivitamins and
stuff actually lately mom told me to
start taking prenatal
yeah that's good for you
i think i should start doing that you
should get ready for a baby
i'm gonna be the best aunt ever jennifer
you're better on it's it's so funny
because now that i'm in a relationship
and it's going swimmingly all she wants
to do is be a grandma and i said whoa
lady i'm 23. you got to pump the brakes
on that she wants a baby yeah she's such
baby fever bad well she says like taking
care of sly is basically like taking
care of a baby yeah except if he's not
as cute
it's just not even close a little bigger
oh slightly weird
not like the cute baby wrinkles you know
but he still burps and uses his diaper
he doesn't have a diaper
potato potato okay
um no i know it's it's funny because i
feel like every time she's around
couples or us when it comes to children
she's always just like when you have
your kids here when you have this here
and it's fun because now i actually am i
mean i'm turning 26 this year i'm not
saying i want a kid anytime soon are you
freaking out about that's pretty old i
know that sounds crazy but for okay let
me rewind
let me rewind it's not that old
when i hear when i hear other people
saying i'm 27 i'm 28 i'm like wow you're
so young but when it's someone that
you've grown up with and seen them as a
baby seeing you as an adult is old to me
do you understand what i'm saying the i
guess like same as a 26 year old is
going to tell me that you still remind
me of a 16 year old i don't feel like
i'm 26
at all i'm not 26 25 but i don't feel
like i'm the age i am at all it's funny
because i remember being younger and you
look at these older kids you go i can't
wait till i'll be 25 i'm gonna have all
my life figured out all this stuff and
then you get to be 25 you're thinking i
am i seriously could be thrown back
senior year of high school and probably
acclimate pretty well i wanted to the
problem my favorite thing i was i looked
up to an older sibling
so much when i was in middle school
seventh and eighth grade i would look at
the seniors in high school i don't look
at the kids that had the older sister
and be like oh my god i want to be that
so bad they're so cool
yeah but you didn't talk to me in high
school that's not true yes it's true
you came over to every single party i
had at my house all the time we were
seniors and enjoyed parties that's
different exactly she just said i wasn't
talking to her at all in high school and
she said we have conjoined parties i'm
triggered because one time i went up to
her and i was like hey sofia i've known
to eat lunch with
can i eat lunch with you and you were
like no why did i say this you were
sitting with the volleyball girls and i
was too young and not cooling when was
this i was quit basketball assistant i
quit volleyball after six months high
school
that's not possible
because i know you played freshman year
sophomore year but you were in you're
two years younger than me that's eighth
grade
perhaps my timeline is
let's actually get into what's the true
topic of what we want to talk about that
was just a ramble cysteine and i
actually haven't really seen each other
for quite a while although we haven't
been at the studio for a while we
literally haven't seen each other that's
why i love not
sharing details with you until we get on
the podcast yeah we actually have a gift
about that fully recap right now
should i start or would you like to
start
um you can start because i feel like
so mine's more done pack i have been out
of town i was in florida for the past
week
it was a very impulsive decision i've
never done anything this last minute i
booked my flight 6 p.m on a saturday and
left early sunday morning with no
luggage
it was
very quick but i was really happy about
it sometimes when you don't overthink a
trip
it's almost easier you know what i mean
i stress out sometimes the whole week
about traveling and packing yeah the
airport getting on time yeah kind of
just throwing yourself into it none of
that was a problem so it was really nice
i spent the week with my family it was
scarlet spring break so i got to see her
and then my aunt and uncle were in town
it was super nice i just felt like
sometimes i
work so hard on
making sure every single relationship
around me
is good and that we're okay and i'm just
nurturing everyone else in my life but i
always seem to put myself in the back
seat and i was like you know what i just
need to sort of reset my brain my body i
want to get back on track and prioritize
myself first for a second and and that's
what i did when i was there and it was
so
helpful i need it that bad yeah i think
everyone manages not feeling okay and
resetting totally different some people
need to be completely alone and isolated
and having their time one-on-one some
people need to be with their family some
people need to get away and just come be
with their friends and i think for us
is that one thing we're big on is family
it's like if you're not feeling great we
will leave at any moment and just go
hang out with our parents or our sister
or whatever it is just so we can and
it's nothing against anybody even if
it's super last minute but
they're the only ones that kind of can
get us back to baseline for sure and i
feel like especially when you're not
okay and you don't feel great
it i think sometimes it's almost worse
when you're alone because you're talking
to yourself a hundred percent i felt
like i was in a bit of a mental rut
and
now that i'm living alone i
was just sitting there and feeling like
okay i have no motivation to go out i
have no motivation to do anything
meet up with friends go get a drink go
to the gym and
actually i sort of compare being in a
mental rut
maybe someone will understand this but
it's sort of like getting back
into the gym after you haven't been
working out for a while it's not so much
working out that's so difficult is
putting on your workout clothes that
you're like oh my god i don't want to do
what i don't want to do but then once
you're there you can do it right and so
i sort of felt like i needed to break
this cycle because yeah you're right
we're so close as a family and i just
knew that like being around mom and dad
and my siblings it would have just
helped and you know i think uh we don't
like acknowledge this but i know we've
been talking about the moving and the
traveling and all this stuff but i mean
we went from having our family all
together to
moving out of our family home to our
parents moving across the country to us
living on our own to like we've had like
i mean obviously make jokes about it but
it's actually a lot bigger of a
transition that we've kind of led on and
i think that for you you're like okay i
kind of needed to be with family and
people around people yeah because when
when you're going through all of that
and then you're just isolated alone it
was like a 100 to zero and so my mom
told me like
maybe i got teary-eyed a night or two
and i was she goes what's wrong and i
said i do not know i was like okay i
just don't feel okay that my my
relationship is great my friendships are
great my family is great i'm healthy i'm
happy but sometimes i just don't know
why i'm sad
and she said you have to understand that
it's okay to not be okay
and i sometimes think that i would
consider myself a mentally strong person
and i don't like to show weakness yeah
in front of people
and the second that i did it was like a
weight just lifted right off my
shoulders yeah well no one's asking you
to be this i know i know you've always
been so vocal and and honest about your
feelings and you went to therapy and
you're okay with
expressing how you feel and then finding
a solution for it whereas i'm so
hard-headed where i'll say i can just
solve it myself yeah but i couldn't
maybe i should go to therapy i don't
think it's a bad thing to get a little
tune up i think it everywhere like cars
you have to put oil in the car to make
it go sometimes you need to get some
fluid for your windshield
sometimes your battery dies you have to
get a new battery i look i just think
that when it comes to mental health and
i mean like i've gone through it i've
always been very vocal about it
i think it's always good just to
acknowledge what's going on and talking
to someone about it and just admitting
that it's okay by the way i like to say
that emotions yeah depending on your
situation this is not for everybody but
when i feel really like in a rut or
unhappy and it's really hard for me to
get in a better mental state
i remember this therapist told me one
time that this is a fleeting emotion you
literally could feel completely
different next week you can feel
completely different in an hour do not
think this is forever and do not think
this is something that you can't control
or fix or manage yeah and i think that's
the best part about when you go through
these things is start you start to learn
a little bit more about yourself oh yeah
what actually is going to help me feel
better and so i'm glad that you went
home to our family and you talked to me
you talked to mom and yeah i think that
now you're starting to get a better grip
of what is going to make you feel better
especially when you have these emotions
because
i could be i'm feeling great right now
like i haven't been like this happy in a
while but oh my god two months ago i was
like completely in shambles like well
i'm super grateful to you and to mom
because you guys have taught me over
just this past week so many tools that
i'll really take to heart and
use because
the things that bother you now and that
you're not willing to address right now
are going to affect you later on in your
life yeah and so i think it's important
for myself and anyone listening that if
you're feeling like sometimes
you are just upset for no reason and
you're in a mental rut and you have no
motivation to do anything that
it's just a fleeting emotion
tomorrow's a new day you could feel even
more sad but it's a different emotion so
yeah day by day it is day by day feeling
good today i do have to say when i was
sad and you called me
you really cheered me up because
you have full-on bangs that you cut and
i said so is she let me tell you this so
while sistine
went to florida to hang out with the
whole family i went to dc but when i got
home i was alone so when i say i was
very isolated i was isolated like i
caught to see some of my friends but
like pretty much every single night
waking up alone eating lunch alone
dinner alone
i had so much fun
but this is the problem never mind this
is the problem i do no i did see my
friends a couple nights a week but i
realized that like sometimes i don't get
when people start to like do impulsive
things when they're alone and they just
decide randomly like i want to just do
this i woke up one of the nights during
the week
probably around like 3 a.m
and i had watched pam and tommy i've
seen all these tick tocks all these cool
hair i was and you were sending me
photos of
this style as well and i go you know
what yeah i was like i want to get bangs
and all of a sudden you beat me to the
side i was like i want to try cutting
them and so i cut long ones and i go
okay that's cool the next morning i
thought they weren't short enough so i
cut a little bit more i mean you
probably can't really see them that much
but
look
when i you did a better job than i
thought but it should just be a psa to
everyone out there
hide your scissors at three in the
morning nothing good is gonna come out
okay
that's true don't do what i did but it
actually came out really good and i
styled it the other night and everyone
thought i literally had bangs you gotta
style it next week i know i'll do it
next week i just am so 50 50 about it i
think i i don't know i think i just
realized how much maintenance bangs are
i'll tell you this so i'm kind of giving
up i
don't think you need bangs because you
have a small forehead and a pretty face
i
always pretty five head
and a big chin you don't have a five
head or a ocean
i do
hence the height you're not like johnny
bravo
that's what people called me in middle
school
and i would do the boys johnny brahma is
cute
it's a man
he's cute though he's tall with a huge
hand
anyway
anyway yes i don't think you should cut
anymore no i won't style it next week
for sure yeah let's talk about you sofia
because your updates are a bit more
exciting
drastic so i was with the parents the
week before in washington dc and this
was not planned but i decided to invite
the guy i was seeing to dc
um and because cesing called me out and
she was like are you eating alone i said
no
um and we made a trip out of it and
during that
trip i have a boyfriend what
round of applause video audience come on
guys
thank you
guys a monumental moment it's been three
years three long complaining years
complaining sad years no i'm actually
really glad that i had those three years
to be single because i think that
i think i i
i'm gonna call you out i'ma stop you
right there
there was not one day of your single
life that you said i'm happy to be
single
not one every day you were complaining
about not being a relationship now that
you're in and she's like you know what i
really appreciated
those years how about me my ears were
bleeding at the moment
you know what it is it's more that i
realized i'm just more i think i tried
to be the single fun chick that you can
like date casually that was funny
that was fun but i can't like i i'm more
of a consistent person i like my routine
i like to know what's going on by the
way
sophia i remember you had this two-week
period and my mom and i would just look
at each other and be like what the hell
is she doing
you tried so hard to convince everyone
around you that you were this like crazy
party girl loves to go out loves the
single life doesn't give an f about who
who got you know what who approaches her
like you were just out and you were
trying so hard to be someone you're not
and we kept saying you sophia you don't
need to go out you could tell you were
tired we're like you can just
sit at home and read like you like to do
and you were just trying to try someone
yourself
you know also if i like stayed home and
didn't do anything either then that
would have been boring as well and i
would have been more sad no 100 i think
every single guy
that you went out with leading up to
this guy was worth it yeah because i do
i asked you guys to each other yeah but
overall the trip was so much fun i feel
like it was
it was okay so it was freezing for one
thing it was so um it's not the weather
being cold so the wind that's what gets
you cold wind is the worst thing in the
world and by the way i'm not a cold
weather person i was born in florida
live in l.a and this weather was just
not it
i'll tell you something
wind
wind if you're watching this
knock it off
no one likes wind no i'm serious that's
what makes it cold
if your wind keeps scrolling if you're a
win
unsubscribe click off click off no but
but it was even as cold as it was
everything was so much fun we'd like
record videos of each other laughing
about how freezing we are and it was
just we went to like great restaurants
but on friday night it was pretty big
because we had to go to this a big event
uh
it's for ruth bader ginsburg it's some
award and uh diana von wiesenberg which
is really cool i got to meet her i was
getting awarded this and also nancy
pelosi was there so all these like
really big really cool people yeah but i
told him i was like do you want to come
and he goes yeah but that was also
he asked me to be his girlfriend and
then also meeting the parents
at the same time in a tuxedo in a tuxedo
for the first time you guys think it's
pretty intimidating just to meet the
parents at the house and do that whole
dinner thing that is a lot of pressure
you brought up to a full-blown
giant political event i didn't realize
how big this event was you had to wear a
suit or like a tuxedo whatever and i
tore a gown i mean i probably should
have just alone been like oh that is
probably a big deal but i didn't realize
how many people were gonna be there but
it ended up being great i mean dad
behaved
well they both really liked him they
they came to me after they said they
really liked him you looked
stunning oh thank you you looked so
gorgeous i was like this is a lucky dude
uh it was really funny though me having
my coffee in the morning the next day
just going on daily mail scrolling along
and up pops sophia and her new beau i
know on dailyvee working not even 24
hours i said dude i told him on the
phone i said you can't get out of this
now it's official we were in vogue you
can't get out of this now you know what
it is is that not that it's been that
long but it feels really good to be in
something else so what about
him makes you feel like
you can have a relationship with this
guy as opposed to other guys that you've
dated you know i actually said this to
him but it was kind of funny and i've
said this to my girlfriends i think they
knew how how different i was acting with
him than the other guys i went out with
but i just knew
i just knew for i just knew from the
first conversation the emotions the
the conversations everything just i in
my gut i'm i was thinking if this
doesn't work
then either i messed up or just
something got
just didn't work in the crossfire i
don't know what would it be but i just
knew at the end of this like something
was gonna become something i don't know
how to explain it it was just you guys
clicked right off the bat yeah and i
think that when people when you're going
out with someone really listen to your
gut like i wish that was one thing i do
wish in the the past relationships that
i was in i kind of tried to force things
like and i thought okay you know what
like i think give it three dates and
then you'll i think of anything three
dates if you're kind of 50 50 but i do
think that
when it comes to something serious and
long term you just know with that person
it's gonna be
a bit more serious or longer or deeper i
don't know well how long has it been
officially now
oh god
two weeks yeah like two weeks i think
i know crazy what are you guys going on
your mental honeymoon
huh because you're in the honeymoon
phase did that one just go right over
your head my mental honeymoon
you're honeymooning right now yeah wait
what do you mean where am i going on my
mentor are you bored bored again oh
oh well what would i go um i say tuscany
i want some good wine oh
yeah we'll we'll be hanging out there
but it feels good i'm happy i'm happy
for you i always think it's interesting
when you start dating someone that you
start to pick up
on their mannerisms and habits and then
you start to do it yourself
uh i don't think i've gone to that level
yet level no well you're you guys are
both together all the time like i don't
have that luxury i've sort of developed
a habit that i'm not exactly proud of
because you actually mentioned this an
old episode red flags with dating guys
if they have a yelp account
that means they're a complainer and yeah
and i'm
that person now
you what do you mean like you write yelp
reviews so my boyfriend is a big foodie
and he won't go to a restaurant unless
he like researches it on yelp looks at
the photos looks the menu see if it's
appetizing the old me would have just
said
anything on this street will work yeah
but he really cares about having a good
meal which i appreciate
no
i find myself when i'm bored just
scrolling on yelp for fun and reading
menus for fun and i used to make fun of
people like that and now i leave reviews
on yelp no it's funny no i kind of do
the same and not the same but when i'm
about to do something maybe book
something or there's something exciting
coming up i'm always saying like would
they have fun at that too and i used to
never care like oh yeah like i'll go and
i'll invite my friends and see who wants
to come but you're always like now
considering like are they gonna like
this no i'm i'm like a legit food critic
now if yelp photos
of the food don't look appetizing i'm
like it's not a good restaurant like as
if i would know like you literally
cannot judge it off of a photo but yeah
you can absolutely sometimes i don't
agree because sometimes when the food is
messier it just tastes better than like
perfectly structured food i'm getting a
yes from behind the camera i don't think
that's so true
sophia
sustina
also another thing about dating someone
new is
don't you ever feel like the universe
just alerts all of your exes that you're
taken at the same time yep
has that happened to you at all
absolutely
no but i did run into
two people that i went on a couple dates
with when i was out exactly and you
haven't done that i ran away but you
haven't seen them at all no you're
saying no and now you're official and
you see everyone yeah no i was so
confused i can never see them at all and
then all of a sudden they're coming out
the woodworks
and i'm not i don't i don't know what it
is maybe it's because right when you
close it off like the energy that all
sudden like this it's an energy you but
you had a weird one you had a very weird
one like this was someone that i was
appalled
appalled appalled because how dare you
lose my lose my number i actually i'm
shocked you haven't
me too me too me too
i'll tell you something yeah i like to
stay platonic with my exes
don't give me a look like that from
behind the camera really i agree i think
it's okay to like be on a good
basis i've never had a horrible blowout
breakup where it was screaming get the f
out no i'm always sitting them down
see i'm always the one breaking up
i just realized you know what i you know
what my way i've been asked that and i
was like have you ever been dumped i go
i am i wish
no am i
the villain hi the villain yes we are
i wish before i get back to my other
point
that i would get dumped do you know
how
sad and everyone that's been dumped no
it's like screw you no it's easier it's
easier because okay yeah you feel like
you don't have the power and the control
of the relationship i don't really care
about that but
say if you don't have a legitimate
reason other than just that you're not
happy with them how horrible how do you
explain that to someone
that sucks yeah but i also feel like
getting broken up with out of the blue
when you're in love with someone is ten
times worse well i'm down to try i guess
there's such a difference because when
you break up with someone or if anyone's
broken up with anybody sometimes you
mentally break up with them three months
ahead of time and so by the time you
break up with them
it's a little bit easier but if you're
getting dumped and you do not see it
coming maybe if the vibes are off but
that's yeah it was in long relationships
like things go up and down
so much worse if i was fully in love
with someone and they were super off
with me for two months and then they
dumped me so i'm already upset about us
being off and then they dumped me
horrible i'm so sorry
to
list them out to everyone that has gone
through that oh my well back to what i
was saying
i like to stay platonic so whenever we
would break
up i would always hope to leave it on a
friendly term not texting on the regular
wasn't like
well no this one in particular was one i
did not in fact ever want to hear from
again me too
and i'm sitting in bed
wednesday morning minding enjoying
coffee watching my vanderpump rules
when i get a call
when i get a call from him
i literally felt like i got punched in
the stomach really and then i get a text
from him saying something like
i hope you're doing well
ew
what
what is the point what is gonna what is
the point why do that
i don't i especially with him not sure
and this is one that you just knew
you know it's it's the person that
shouldn't be reaching out
and why do people do it
you know i think sometimes when people
reach out to exes that
they didn't have a good place with it's
something for control i think they want
to know that you're still interested in
them and so if you answered him and
anything if you answered the phone if
you texted him back
anything anything that you giving him
any energy would have made him feel well
that's why i felt really good about
ghosting him because this was one
relationship that was so toxic so
unhealthy yeah i was
really
down on myself for months after it like
yeah it did not put me in a good
headspace and so finally having the
control back being like well i'm not
gonna answer you this time i love that
you didn't oh man leaving that kid on
red ah see see ya doing beer don't want
to be yeah that's for sure and i you
wrote this down i like that
you you said that oh yeah mom told me
yeah i like this you said she said that
you want to say it do you want to say it
no you can say it because it's mom told
you obviously it's
yeah no i told my mom this and she said
that sometimes you need to go through
the bad ones to realize how strong you
can be without them
can i get an amen mic drop seriously
though that's why i said like
i would rather
go go through all of the bad dates yeah
boyfriends everything all of the hard
times yeah over and over again if it
meant being with the one that i'm with
right now because it was worth it i
completely agree with that because i
would rather i'm happy that i was
actually i know that people remember oh
yeah you want a relationship but i was
happy i was single that entire entire
time not chose someone that was
not as good for me and i didn't listen
to
like that insecure side of me going like
i should just be in one because i need
to be in one because now i'm in one
where it's just so easy and we're
laughing all the time and it's so
healthy and oh my god i can't wait for
your first fight i know i don't know
it's so hard i'm in like the honeymoon
phase so everything's so great yeah
you're in
italy in your head right now i know
give it a few months i know i know sorry
no one of the things that we really
missed about doing sister episodes was
bringing back our og segments
in the beginning of this podcast we
would have our weekly updates our
unsolicited advice our bedtime stories
our conspiracy theories and we sort of
just let those dissipate as the episodes
have gone on so well we've been
interviewing people yeah but i just miss
them so today we're gonna bring in a
bedtime story
sophie and i always go back and forth on
what we should talk about we love just
exposing ourselves in embarrassing ways
and i saw a tick tock that really just
triggered
me in all the right ways
it was a tick tock of
this little girl at a rodeo
and she was riding some oversized lamb
as if it was like a mini bowl like it
was a bull riding competition
and they have the same competition but
for ages what would you say like six to
eleven yeah
and they ride these oversized lamps and
they take off and they hold on yeah for
dear life
and but that's so funny because i saw
that tick tock and i sent it to my
boyfriend i was like i did this [ __ ] so
i won our bedtime story today is the
time
my mom signed sophia and i up for the
same exact competition in a rodeo and
the results were
excellent they're excellent so we are in
montana or why was it montana wyoming
montana montana and we show up and we're
about to watch a bull riding competition
it's our first time we're easily 10
years old right he's probably like
no i was probably
seven
i was i was a little i guess my number's
off so i was whatever it is
but we get there we're sitting in the
stands and it's a huge arena there are
like hundreds of people there all super
fanatics about bull riding horseback
riding all that stuff so and we have our
little stupid get up on like we don't
we're not western writers or anything
yet so my mom buys like hats and like
flannels and boots and so we have the
whole thing we walk in like we know
what's going on she's with uh her sister
and her three daughters and they thought
it would be absolutely hilarious to sign
up
six little girls during like
intermission for whatever
right into this competition so i
remember i got on first and i had no
idea what to expect so this intermission
was
seeing who can hang on to the sheep the
longest and when
and these sheep are not like nice they
are yeah it's not like a little pony
ride in our circle one animal wants an
eight-year-old on its back none so of
course it's gonna get so angry and
aggressive so i i don't remember a lot
of things
when i was young but this is one memory
that is so burned into my head i
remember getting on holding on all fours
and they opened the gate and it went so
fast that my body just flew off the back
of it
like
wrap your legs and wrap your arms around
its neck it's a bear hug and i it went
so fast out of this gate that it left my
body in the gate all the cousins and
sustained everyone tried i'm last right
and so
they all were falling off the sides oh
it's like rolling in the dirt it's all
like a graceful oh yeah you're getting
bucked off this sheep
and so i'm thinking okay i gotta do a
different strategy here
i gotta win this competition so instead
of holding onto the neck for some reason
i'm like wait maybe if i grab onto the
stomach like wrap my arms on the stomach
and the other stomach or my legs and my
arms that i'll be more gripped like
they're holding on to the neck and it's
just not working
gates open i'm holding on and i'm going
and it's going
hanging on but this is the best part
halfway across the arena
i'm about to fall i'm sliding under the
side i'm under the sheet so now she's
literally hanging under the sheep so her
mouth is at the sheep's mouth oh my gosh
and she's still she's got a crazy grip
it was not nice it was so angry so mean
it was giving me this like it was like
drooling on my face
i have a video of this i needed to
finally i like let go and it tramples me
because i'm under him and i end up
winning the the rodeo competition but
you see me i'm covered in dirt i'm so
proud of myself that i won this
competition i just find it so funny
because i saw that girl doing it i'm
like yeah that was me one time i'm
definitely putting my kids and stuff i
love when parents sort of embarrass
children like that i think it's so funny
oh it's hilarious i i you i feel like if
you're going to take your kids on trips
and sometimes i'm like oh you shouldn't
bring your baby on vacation but if
you're going to take your kids on trips
make them do really funny things where
you know that you're gonna they're gonna
want videos of it later photos you know
what even as a parent you need to have
some fun too you can't be providing all
the fun grab a beer put your kid on a
sheep
and enjoy and press record we're
definitely gonna find a video of that i
know we need it it is so hysterical yeah
all right you guys we haven't done this
in such a long time and it's my favorite
segment of all time because we get to
talk to you and so we are gonna do
unsolicited advice
and you know how it goes you have to go
on apple podcast five stars nothing less
four stars we don't acknowledge it and
write your question there and we also
love when you guys write a little bit of
a nice letter to us saying that we are
sisters you never had because that's our
goal here i do have to say i've been
reading the comments a lot lately that
people have been leaving in our podcast
page and uh
um i would say about 99 of them are
stellar lovely seller so sweet love all
of you guys and we had
five stars
now we have 4.9 star rating because one
person
what do you mean
i won't call you up
one person captioned it i tried
i tried to love this podcast just can't
get her into this duo and you know what
reality tv junkie all day
one star
not nice just don't comment anything
you didn't try hard enough you know what
if your title is reality tv junkie all
day we should be getting along that's me
that was the whole last episode was
about how much we love it we had a
reality star on well we hope you can
change your mind and your rating because
it kind of ruined our good streak but
we'll let it go meet us here 12 o'clock
tomorrow i didn't guarantee we'll change
it oh how is we'll interview you oh
oh i'm scared okay this is
the question written in by diana m jk
she wrote the sisterly advice i need
thank you guys so much for starting this
podcast it brings so much joy and i hear
your stories and feel like i'm not alone
in my life adventures and i'm not the
only one going through things
you're not girl
i know that no matter where i'm at my
life you guys have an episode that'll
make me feel better and give advice i
need that's so nice well you'll love
this one
need some unsolicited advice after a
year of off in a history of dating toxic
men
retweet
i'm trying to get back into dating i've
gone on some dates and i've been bold
enough to give guys i find attractive my
number that's awesome
i'm a go-getter and i don't mind making
the first move here i'm also trying to
work on my manifestations and crystal
work sophia okay i don't do that much
but okay
i'm not really seeing the results i want
because
they're crystals
the guys i've dated haven't been what
i'm looking for and the one i really
like
wanted to go out with ended up being
taken oops
it happens
any advice on what i could be doing
differently here especially in my
manifestations or crystals maybe ways i
can present myself so guys come up to me
first thank you so much for being so
genuine fun and willing to help us out
okay
okay
diana where do i begin so i i feel like
we don't know enough about her dating
mannerisms and her first move
uh tactics to give give tweaks on what
she's doing but what you've said so far
about how you're bold enough to
go up to someone and give them your
number shows confidence and that is
like study show that is literally the
number one thing guys look for it right
off the bat yeah so you have that down
yeah you know i actually was gonna say
if anything that would be the number one
thing i'd suggest if you hadn't already
said that because i think that
it's good to also know what you want if
you're feeling someone and you have a
connection with someone it's always good
just to put yourself out there that's
the first thing if you're trying to find
someone you always have to put yourself
out there you have to go on
i know sometimes look i hate dating apps
too you don't have to do it and it works
sometimes like it does and i've seen
success stories i've seen fails as well
just like everything in life but
i don't think you need it i think that
you have a good group of friends you
find them you go out
say to people that you're single say
that you want to be set up with friends
sometimes it's a little easier when you
kind of have at least a
ground to work on when you kind of know
maybe someone of someone but when it
comes to the spiritual side with like
manifestations and crystals i look i
always have said i think crystals and
manifestations are great and i like them
i don't do them a lot but i actually one
thing that actually has kind of changed
my mindset a while has been i've been
writing down like three things i'm
grateful in the morning for and i write
one manifestation like i am
strong this this and i'm open to big
changes and it just kind of gets my mood
in the morning right and i promise i
know it sounds really weird so singing
and you're gonna like judge me for this
but i actually feel like i've seen a
shift in my life since i've been doing
i've been doing it for two months now
and i just feel like a lot of good
things have happened it's because when
you are acknowledging the positive
things that you want you're going to
notice the positive things that are
happening for you as opposed to if
you're only
upset and anticipating bad things to
happen to you in the future then you're
just waiting for the bad thing to happen
so for that side i don't you don't need
the crystals i mean they work and
they're fun for
jewelry and things like that and good
energy no but they are like i like when
people wear crystals around their
neckline yeah i think that's cool but i
think that if you want to do the
manifestation part which i'm very much
into do that i bought some journal on
amazon and it just does it once a day
and it has a quote and i think for
yourself it's a good shift and maybe you
can see a difference in yourself first
thing in the morning when you do it yeah
but for the other side for dating so you
said that you've been
dating toxic man or you have a history
of dating toxic men i am right there
with your sister
and what i've realized was
you can't change these guys they're
insecure in their own reason
and for whatever reason they choose to
be toxic
it's my responsibility to not let that
come into my life and i realized that
when
i started showing self-love to myself
and then i stopped attracting those
toxic men in my life because i
found
a sort of middle ground of i deserve
someone that treats me like this so the
second i started looking at myself in
higher regard and held myself to a
higher standard and told myself that i
deserve better
then an amazing guy will see those same
things in you but when i was dating
toxic men it's because i wouldn't say i
was toxic but i didn't have any
self-worth but i think what you need to
do different is just
let it go i don't think you need to put
a lot of pressure on finding someone i
think that when i found somebody i
wanted a relationship for three years
but i didn't
put pressure on it like i was like you
know what when the right one comes it
will work and it literally just worked i
hate that cliche when they're like when
you least expect it but it's not even
when you leave but especially
gonna come eventually they will they're
gonna come the person that you're
supposed to be is gonna show up and
they're gonna be the right one for you
and you know it because they're gonna
give you as much energy maybe a little
more
that you're giving to them i think
that's what i realized was when i was
dating someone that i knew was different
was that our energy is aligned like they
know exactly what they want and they
wanted you and you know exactly what you
want and you wanted them but i do want
to applaud you continue being forward
and upfront about what you want because
that's super important that shows
confidence and your boldness rocks so
best of luck to you keep us updated
patience confidence
and keep working on yourself and then
you'll find yeah baby okay i think that
wraps the episode yeah i thought that
was fun
well chaotic thank you guys so much for
joining this new week's episode it was
fun it was crazy and now it's fun that c
and i both have boyfriends so maybe
we'll talk about double dates if we
maybe we'll bring them on they will
never come on but okay we'll force them
out of this we'll blindfold them tell
them hon we're going to take you on
put them in this chair and be like
welcome to unlock so maybe if you guys
want us to do it down for kidnapping
okay well thank you guys for tuning in
remember if you want your unsolicited
advice answered go to the apple podcast
page leave your question in the ratings
and review section that is the only way
we're gonna look at it and we will see
you next tuesday bye
[Music]
you